pour bien comprendre les enjeux de ce
dossier du gaz russe nous sommes en
ligne avec francis perrin bonjour
bonjour vous êtes directeur de recherche
à l'iris et chercheur associé au policy
center for de news of alors vladimir
poutine l'exigent il faudra payer la
facture de gaz en roubles même si les
contrats stipulent le contraire on ne
voit pas très bien comment ça va se
solder en ce bras de fer et qui sera le
premier a cédé d'autant que se passe
d'autant que total pardonnez-moi le se
passer du gaz russe pour les pays
européens ça paraît compliqué
comme vous l'avez rappelé cette exigence
russe est complètement illégal
les contrats passés si lié de longue
date entre la russie en l'occurrence
gazprom et des sociétés gazières
européennes
prévoient le paiement du gaz russe en
euros ou en dollars et un contrat ne
peut pas être changé de façon
unilatérale par l'une des parties c'est
la base du droit des contrats et
vladimir poutine de sait parfaitement
alors pourquoi est ce qu'il fait ça il
fait ça pour parler familièrement pour
embêter les européens pour faire
pression sur eux qu'ils allègent le
poids des sanctions économiques contre
la russie et pour tenter de faire
remonter le cours du rouble
par contre on entend différents sons de
cloches hamsun pendant que monsieur
poutine dit j'ai signé un décret à
partir de maintenant vous payer le gaz
en route c'est une obligation son porte
parole monsieur nuit tri peskov dit cela
va s'appliquer de façon progressif est
par ailleurs le chancelier allemand olaf
scholz le premier ministre italien
monsieur mario draghi expliquent ils se
sont entretenus avec vladimir poutine et
qu' ils ont retenu de ces discussions
que rien ne changeait pour les allemands
et pour les italiens et donc on voit
bien qu'il ya une part de bluff je ne
dirais pas d'être un poisson d'avril
dépit de la date mais en tout cas au
minimum par deux dans la décision entre
guillemets décision de vladimir poutine
il teste les européens il teste la
solidarité européenne dont ils lancent
comme ça des ballons d'essai
spectaculaire qui vont faire le buzz à
travers le monde et puis ensuite il voit
quelle est la réaction cela ne veut pas
dire que dès aujourd'hui dès demain la
russie va couper le robinet du gaz parce
que les européens ne paieront pas ou
alors les européens dans le même temps
se tourner vers d'autres partenaires
pour leur approvisionnement il ya le gn
gnl le gaz naturel liquéfié américain
d'autres accords peuvent être être en
train de se nouer mais cela suffira-t-il
alors les européens union européenne
deux objectifs
premièrement à court terme c'est à dire
dans un délai d'un an réduire de façon
importante les importations de gaz russe
deuxième l'objectif à moyen terme
environ cinq ans se passer complètement
du gaz et du pétrole russes et pour cela
pour le premier comme pour le deuxième
objectif il faut commencer à travailler
maintenant dès 2020 travail et selon
quels axes trois axes clés premièrement
aller chercher de gaz ailleurs le
diamant remplacer une parking notre
consommation gazière par d'autres
énergies notamment des renouvelables
troisièmement faire des économies sur
notre consommation actuelle de gaz sur
le premier point où aller chercher le
gaz d'abord aux états unis principal
allié de l'union européenne premier
producteur mondial de gaz premier
exportateur mondial de gaz naturel
liquéfié et l'action genzyme avançait un
accord etats unis union européenne sur
des livraisons supplémentaires de gnl
américain à partir de 2022 et cela va
monter en puissance dans les années qui
viennent mais les jeunes ne seront pas
la solution parce que personne ne peut
être la solution aux problèmes russes
pour le gaz il faudra trouver d'autres
pays des négociations sont en cours avec
le qatar avec
afrique l'algérie l'egypte le nigeria
avec en europe les pays bas et
l'azerbaïdjan et d'autres pays sont
seront contactés notre pays gazier
l'idée c'est vraiment de mettre ensemble
si je puis dire plusieurs pays chacun
apportant une partie de la solution en
n'oubliant pas que la solution ce n'est
pas seulement aller chercher du gaz
ailleurs c'est une des trois options les
deux autres étant de remplacer une
partie de notre consommation gazière par
d'autres énergies et de faire des
économies sur notre consommation
actuelle de gaz donc les plans européens
repose sur une conjonction entre ces
trois acteurs et pas seulement sur un
facteur aller chercher du gaz est alors
sur aller chercher du gaz ailleurs
justement l'un des pays aux ressources
importantes c'est l'iran en accord
pourrait être très bientôt signer sur la
question du nucléaire ce qu'il lèverait
les sanctions et qui permettrait d'avoir
accès à ses réserves de pétrole
notamment
oui vous avez raison l'iran est un pays
important dans l'équation mais à court
terme à court terme veulent environ 2000
22 ce sera plus une réponse pétrolière
et gazière de l'iran a un potentiel
énorme de pétrole et de gaz naturel il a
les deux sixième plus grosses réserves
prouvées de gaz naturel dans le monde
après la russie sauf que l'iran exporte
de degas ce parce qu'il n'a pas les
infrastructures
aujourd'hui lui permettant de le faire
cela viendra dans les années qui
viennent mais ce n'est pas une solution
pour les approvisionnements gaziers
européens en 2022 parcours pour le
pétrole l'iran pourrait s'il ya un
accord à vienne autriche autour de son
programme nucléaire et que les états
unis lèvent une bonne partie de leurs
sanctions économiques contre l'iran ce
pays serait en mesure dont les mois qui
viennent je dis bien dans les mois qui
viennent de produire et d'exporter plus
de pétrole est en ce moment au niveau
européen et au niveau mondial nous avons
un problème pour le gaz naturel et nous
avons un problème ou un problème
potentiel pour le pétrole donc l'iran
pourrait contribuer à non pas être la
solution mettre une solution pour le
pétrole puisque pour le gaz à cordes
merci beaucoup francis perrin pour votre
éclairage ce